stay down I wanted it you be dead
already
today is a day for truth with Batman V
Superman I wanted to continue this tone
that we established in Man of Steel but
i really want to recapture some of the
cinematic qualities of the movies that I
loved that inspired me that's how it
starts the fever the rage but turns good
men
cool we spent a lot of time and we're
very careful about where we would go for
the next journey into the DC Universe we
knew we had established a Clark
kent/superman character in a world that
we now could build out from this means
something to all some people have it's
all that gives him hope we just felt
like it was an original and interesting
concept to pit him against another hero
but a darker hero
and Batman was the perfect foil
tell me
once you enter such a fantastical world
is Batman vs Superman and you take a
real-world product and company like
Turkish Airlines and you bring it in to
you know really set the world as real
that's the thing that I was inspired by
as a filmmaker and I felt like wow we
have created what we believe is pretty
fantastical world for Batman vs Superman
in the sense that you have these two
superheroes battling it out but the
presence of Turkish Airlines really
makes me feel like these things are
actually happening this away Clark Kent
Daily Planet what's your position on the
bath vigilante in Gotham Turkish
Airlines has this motto of wine your
world and the interesting thing and the
way that that's played incredibly well
into what we've done as film is that
we've literally widened the world by
creating these two mythical cities of
Gotham and metropolis maybe it's the
Gotham City and me we just have a bad
history with freaks dressed like clowns
the thing that got me excited about
Turkish Airlines was their global reach
you know and that they're a global brand
and that they could bring to our project
his awareness and they represent a
certain quality of product that is
really a high level and it's a great
relationship for us because we try and
create a product that has you know high
pressure high conceptual value and i
think that the relationship with turkish
airlines that's really exciting for us
you
hey youtubers is charlie new Batman V
Superman teaser Batman vs Superman I'm
gonna have so much fun watching these
guys fight there's still a lot we don't
know about zack snyder's batman you know
most of my takeaway has been that it's
inspired by Frank Miller's Dark Knight
Returns Batman not quite as old as that
Batman but a lot of his toys look very
similar just with a slightly more modern
spin on it because this is happening in
present day like the world of today and
when Frank Miller wrote his Batman it
was happening in a dystopian future
version that was actually relatively
close to where we are right now I really
loved reading those old stories we're
like a tease writers have this fascist
take on present-day like our present day
2015 2016 right now but it seems like
this fight comes after this fight
because that man finally confronts him
in the street you know do you bleed you
will Superman even told him the next
time they light up the bat signal do not
answer it the bat is dead so Batman
probably armors up turns the light on to
go Superman into a fight and then tries
to take him down and I love how quickly
Superman shuts him down you can tell
Superman really hates the idea of Batman
he doesn't want to kill him post Man of
Steel's odd killing he's probably
already made up his mind that he's not
going to do that anymore unless they
jump forward a lot in time he's still in
his freshman year Superman's so he's
still probably not super hot with the PR
in front of Congress what are your
intentions you have the power of a god
how can we trust you that you're not
going to crush us like soda cans in the
comics that trust is earned just over a
long period of time Superman approves
time and time again that he's here to
help not to hurt people although Frank
Miller Dark Knight Returns a lot of
those hardcore 80s writers did address
the idea of collateral damage and that's
really where it seems like the Batman
character is flowing from look you say
you want to help us but you destroyed
half of a city there's a chance you
could go rogue so we have to make sure
that that doesn't happen we're getting
so close to the movie I'm really curious
to see what kinds of other marketing
that they try out like they finally
started having Henry Cavill do you know
the benevolent Superman funny videos
where he asked little kids who do you
think would win in a fight Batman or
Superman I have heard a lot of people
talking about little kids being confused
in theaters as to why Batman and
Superman are fighting and I don't think
that's really the fault of the marketing
or the film like if you gave a little
kid Dark Knight Returns he or she
probably really confused as to why old
Batman hates the [ __ ] out of old
Superman so a lot of it just boils down
to like what your idea
the tone of Superman is I'm actually
really excited the movie is supposed to
be two and a half hours long which is
longer than Avengers age of Ultron so
there's just like so much of it that we
haven't seen yet most of the stuff that
I think they're keeping close to the
vest is the related justice league stuff
you know Aquaman flash cyborg Green
Lantern's that kind of stuff I think
there's stuff like that in the movies
just the narrative of the film is Batman
going up against Superman Lex Luthor
trying to pit them against each other
with Wonder Woman stuck in the middle
trying to keep things from going to [ __ ]
that's another question do you guys like
it when superhero movies like this like
the comic book movies are longer I think
Deadpool is a really good example of a
film that's not longer than it needs to
be I would totally be willing to pay an
inflated movie ticket price for a
three-hour superhero film the other
really exciting news tonight is the
Gotham is back there doing Hugo Strange
it's BD Wong if you don't know who he is
he was in the Jurassic Park movies you
probably recognize them even if you
don't know his name he was in mr. robot
he is amazing he's gonna be Hugo Strange
he's already my favorite thing about the
show and the episode hasn't even aired
yet that should tell you all you need to
know new Gotham tonight be sure to
subscribe to get that I'll post my video
after the episode airs why you guys wait
for me to post that Gotham video tonight
you can click here for my last big
Batman V Superman trailer video and you
can click here from walking dead from
last night in case you missed it in all
the Oscars craziness thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight
you